who is the toughest guy in the world I
mean who is the baddest dude in the
world I want to see this in what way did
you say they wake up and in yeah in
weight class I mean that's what's
fascinating I think that ultimately will
win the game will win the day you know
you you just have to you just have to
give people the ability to show their
best foot I don't think it's all
completely up to the fighter to have to
raise their star quality value I think
it really you'll see to promote Iraq
tell their story correctly like let me
just focus on training and winning every
flight possible you guys deal with these
guys are basing my agents and managers
you guys get me in the right position
become a star yeah i'm just going to
keep winning right you lined up the very
best guys in the world let me win then
you make me the stars right instead of
having guys where it's not really their
thing now that gotik talk trash they got
to create a whole fiasco around it so
media which I understand is a business
but media becomes really important and
for the guys that just are not that way
they're just not it's not their thing
they're just pure fighters pure athletes
now there's all this pressure for them
to kind of like it step outside and kind
of like create hype a few hundred aces
conor mcgregor conor mcgregor's got a
golden time to get worse too with WME
you know you guys on Conan and you're
gonna see guys in movies and on more TV
you know yeah that's where i think it
was Domitius the process i agree i think
that that whole thing is is compromising
the sport for those reasons and it's a
[ __ ] bummer man so a bummer for
people who are real fans of the sport
and I and I find it insulting to the two
guys like Jacare and you'll Romero and
all these guys so that matter could be
in there another mount that off he's
fighting for fighting for time yeah so
if time just look at maybe bathe her
neck and then what would you be open to
it like a chill even though chillin just
long are you down for those gangster
wait fight oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
put a right guys yeah absolutely I you
know what I feel like I train with heavy
weights and I do well with heavy weights
when you start talking about like the
top heavyweights in the world I'm like
what to fight no but you don't put in
Bellator like if you fought fatal I take
you over fader if you fought metreon
take your mission if you do cheick kongo
give me Phil Davis like if I guess I go
through the current list of heavyweights
in belt or I I got you favored in all
the sights yeah it was you know Shirley
I'm he walks around you know he's got to
third dude chills not the same shell how
was the last time you saw him ah four
weeks ago he was in here Oh before its
fighter after uh before well he was
already small for his fight but yeah I
saw him probably a month before that he
was looking small I've only seen chelle
smaller than me a couple times in my
life we fought together in LA back in
the day he fought uh Anderson that night
ok for Anderson ok up that night I
fought uh Rodney Wallace oh gotcha
rodney rogers yeah that's my third fight
in and I took you know look it also ate
rider line diffuser rodney was ok anyway
um give me fight no but um you will you
referring to jail back in the yeah TRT
exemption jail yeah yeah he's nowhere
near that side down more none of the
crazies he's definitely smaller yeah we
surprised he used to be your size she's
like a anthony johnson guy training
together yeah and we I thought he was
big man he's like you know one of the
best things about you is you don't
realize your size I'm like [ __ ] we're
the same size like City Plaza you keep
saying how like into her though because
I'm bigger we're the guys matter of fact
you might be Baker what are you talking
about were you surprised with outcome of
a tito and she'll completely blown away
i have money on them you got money on
jail i had money on shell all might was
funny of today before i went to watch
penn state vs Iowa in Iowa wrestling
match so me and my boys met out and we
went to the match it was awesome then
afterwards we all stick around and watch
the bellator fights and they're like who
you got feels like I got jail and they
all picked ido really how are they fans
of the sport
they just know T turkey so famous you
know I'm saying exactly they just kind
of know Tito from TV sounds like aah
thank you guys and so I bet three people
they all want it they won't want an
action I said okay they wanted actually
what did I oh you're good that's for you
plus it all right cool I'll take that
bet dude I'm usually pretty good at MMA
bet I've friendship they've got a lot of
money on MMA and they go Tito chalant
honestly man I think you know Tito it's
his last fight you got one foot out the
door you know chill wants this he spot
you know we work I just feel like chill
shouldn't be on the fight I couldn't be
more proud of 40 but you know he's lying
i can i couldn't have smooth antimony i
lay down and he can and before you did
handles ya know yet he has a full mouth
[ __ ] him but this is an actor after
I've definitely had it later i wasn't me
to tell that your time is awesome yeah
but will you punish that little hobby I
worry about Richie incognito which
you'll like do you remember which
incognito I've heard the story little
Richie yeah but do you remember the
offensive guard or tackle and lots of
money better play for hours anyway they
forgot what was all-pro this year you
remember when you went oh my god when
were that guy was coming up to him you
see that was the blonde football player
that happened to have been rich
incognito I don't know if you know that
they came up and talked to us when he
picked that guy up over his head and
threw him on his back do not remember
this did Brian fantasizing a friend bubs
remarried you went oh my god he oh yes
that's right keep that was Richie
incognito my god oh god kept grabbing i
rewrite a top and tight jeans are like
God and he kept coming up to Richie and
I was going looking over going that
batteries in I mean he's a blond
silverback he's a he's a blonde
silverback gorilla to the fullest dude
he he hell of a football player hello
football player he I asked him he'd bet
he squats 800 pounds I asked him and
I've never I couldn't believe how thick
he was and kind of handsome guy with my
wife a hottie like I'm it's like it's
like literally Richie incognito and then
fast forward his human evolution and
Elon Musk raised like crazy and he and
he picked this guy up like over his head
and just so unpack what
guy kept coming up to him and like
challenging him yeah and ever when you
went oh my god and then you know you
said to him you go brother what what was
that about you just you hoisted him up
and threw him down he goes I you name is
just getting a little mouthy and kind of
in my face and touching and I kept
asking to get away she's a little lesson
yes moms because it literally looked
like oh it would have been a fake
wrestling move if he had enough slammed
into the earth by the way the creepiest
thing is a magic behind almost coming
out of this guy going hey my man what do
you squat on the curiosity you're like
you using Goering attic block you don't
kiss the ring with MJ because that's all
he gets she will go back and forth with
you and he's and he's just funny and
cool and all those things but he's the
only guy you know listen he was this is
back in the day when he was winning
championships and killing it you can't
get to the night ago yeah so with him I
got a press pass and I went backstage
with a cameraman and I got was sitting
with all the press at his locker and
he's just naked standing there we're all
just you know and you know people it was
like a wave it was just like is it is it
easier not now that Rodman's here in
terms of you know him taking some of the
heat what do you think it is is it
matter to have 72 73 wins and then i
said and i'm waiting for the wave and i
go have you let the healing begin since
you were snubbed at the Oscars for Space
Jam hahaha that's allure silence it
really like god damn it and he's kind of
just i'm looking into six foot six naked
jordan he looks at me cuz all i know
this dude you were clown man this dude's
a clown i get it what's up man